welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marcia in Hoorn the William Kalin
Mann junior professor of anthropology
and international affairs at yale
university professor in horns research
interests revolve around science and
technology studies gender and feminist
theory including masculinity studies
religion and bioethics globalization and
global health cultures of bio medicine
and ethno medicine stigma and human
suffering over the past 20 years she has
conducted multi-sided research on the
social impact of infertility and
assisted reproductive technologies in
Egypt Lebanon the United Arab Emirates
and Arab America her many books include
local babies global science gender
religion and in vitro fertilization in
Egypt and infertility and patriarchy the
cultural politics of gender and family
life in Egypt today we talk with
professor in Hoorn about her new book
the new Arab man emergent masculinities
technologies and Islam in the Middle
East
welcome professor in Hoorn Thank You
Marilyn I'm really pleased to be here
let's begin with an overview of your
book tell us about it ok well this book
I have to say is a real labor of love it
was basically 10 years in the making and
you know based on your introduction all
of my work I'm a medical anthropologist
and a gender scholar and I've worked for
20 years in the Middle East and almost
all of my work up until this point had
been on women suffering from infertility
and the kinds of difficult treatment
decisions they had to make their quest
for conception the introduction of in
vitro fertilization into the region in
the very late 1980s and you know sort of
the changing trajectory of how people
who were childless could overcome their
infertility and during this long
any of about 20 years of looking at
infertility is a global reproductive
health issue I realized that the sort of
missing component our men is men and men
themselves contribute to more than half
of the world's infertility problems male
infertility is really what we would call
a neglected global reproductive health
issue and it can actually be very
serious intractable uncurable chronic
it's often genetic in origin and so
after having written three books on
Egypt focusing mostly on women the last
one focusing a little bit on the men as
well I decided that I needed to do a
study in the Middle East of this large
problem of male infertility and that
ended up taking me to Lebanon for
complicated reasons but I went in the
year 2003 and did a very long and very
intensive study of Middle Eastern men
from Lebanon Palestine Syria and from a
number of other places to talk to them
about not only their infertility but
their support and commitment to their
infertile wives and in fact yes so that
was it is about infertility and men's
engagement with assisted reproductive
technologies to overcome it but I would
say the largest theme of this book well
beyond the infertility and the assisted
reproductive technologies in play in the
Middle East is really about
middle-eastern men's changing lives and
I think the the most important thing is
that really we have now hundreds of
books by scholars and and other people
describing various aspects of women's
lives in the Middle East most of them
women you know women's political
involvement women's changing you know
norms and practices and education and so
on but men
men Middle Eastern men as men really
have not been studied in terms of
masculinity their sense of self their
hopes for the future and so through this
lens of men who were going through
difficult issue with their wives I
learned so much about masculinity and
just about shifting generational norms
in the region and so I ended up writing
a book that's as much about Arab
masculinity as it is about treatment for
infertility and I think that is really
the big message of the book is that
there are emergent masculinities new
kinds of manhood shifting notions about
being a man in the region today and
that's what I think is the big message
of this book okay one of the things that
really surprised me that I think many
people are not aware of is the high rate
of infertility
what is the number basically globally if
you look at any given population in the
world this sort of average is anywhere
between ten and fifteen percent some of
the regions of the world have much
higher in fertility rates particularly
sub-saharan Africa for all sorts of
reasons the Middle Eastern region is
sort of in the global average I mean a
country like Egypt with about 80 million
people has about a 15 percent rate of
infertility among married couples
now within infertility generally
speaking it's said that about 30 to 40
percent of cases are female infertility
problems 30 to 40 percent of cases are
male infertility problems and then the
rest twenty percent or so our combined
male and female infertility problems so
if you take the male issues altogether
it's said that about half of all cases
of childlessness involve a male
infertility problem in the Middle East
if you go to IVF clinics across the
region the rates of male infertility are
much higher than that in clinics that
I've worked in it's between 60 70 % of
all cases I have heard from others that
there's some regions in the Middle East
where up to 90 percent of couples coming
into clinics there will be a male
infertility problem so male infertility
is a serious problem in the
middle-eastern region
and why is that do you think is there
any reason
yeah actually so now what's understood
about male infertility is that a lot of
it is genetic it's actually little
mutations often on the y chromosome they
can be spontaneous or they may be
related to just genetic defects and they
can run in families and so it's now
realized with you know increase things
are genetic sophistication that a lot of
male infertility has a genetic origin in
the Middle Eastern region and in other
regions of the world many regions of the
world there are high rates of what's
called consanguineous marriage where
people marry within their families okay
that cousins may marry each other first
cousins second cousins and that probably
increases the rates of male factor
infertility because genetic defects you
know that occur in close unions then get
passed on to offspring so what you will
find in a country like Lebanon is whole
families with you know several brothers
who are infertile several first cousins
uncles and so forth that there's
actually clustering of male infertility
and families and it's very devastating
for those families where you know
several men are having trouble
conceiving I met many of those cases in
the course of my research okay let's
talk about how you did your research
what was your methodology yes so for
about since in vitro fertilization IVF
which is the sort of base form of
assisted reproduction has come to the
region in the late 1980s it came to
Egypt Saudi Arabia and Jordan in 1986
I've been very fortunate to be able to
work in IVF clinics in a variety of
countries and often because very nice
IVF physicians have decided that they
were willing to let me come and do a
project in their clinical population so
I've worked in a number of IVF clinics
in in the Middle East as well as in the
Arab American population in Michigan and
I have you know sort of participated in
the lives of these clinics and I have
done very in-depth what we would call
anthropological or ethnographic
interviews with
hundreds of people I have now you know
at last count I have interviewed more
than 300 men both fertile and infertile
men from about 14 different
middle-eastern countries the majority
have been Egyptian Lebanese Syrian and
Palestinian I've done a lot of solo
interviews with just men I've done a lot
of solo interviews with women and I've
done hundreds of couple interviews
together so you know and often you know
people these are long interviews where
people open up and tell me many intimate
aspects of their lives
I'm going to say that must have been I
would have imagined and assumed that if
that would be very difficult for a man
to sit down and talk with a Western
woman so to speak about that kind of
thing how did you get past that I would
imagine hesitation or yeah so that
that's an interesting story actually
because I had always worked with women
throughout the 1980s and early 1990s
until I went back to do my first study
in in vitro fertilization clinics in
Cairo Egypt and they're intending only
to work with women I was sort of ushered
into these you know hospital rooms where
women were recovering from various IVF
procedures and their husbands were there
and so the husband's often didn't want
to leave and I ended up in about 40% of
my interviews in Egypt including
husbands in the interviews and that's
where first I discovered that there were
high rates of male infertility many of
these women were going through
procedures because their their husbands
were infertile and men were talkative
they wanted to talk you know and so
these were interviews with couples
together but I realized that there you
know that lack of hesitation on the part
of Egyptian men to talk to me about
their infertility problems was probably
a good sign that maybe I could do this
with men alone and I think we've often
held a lot of untested assumptions and
somehow women can only talk to women
about sensitive or intimate things that
men could only talk to men and I was
abiding by that thinking until I not
only you know the studies I did in Egypt
but I talked to some Middle Eastern male
colleagues and I said I really want to
do this study of male infertility in the
region I see it's a really big issue and
I think I should get a male graduate
student to go do the work and I actually
tried to get a male graduate student to
go do the work and a couple of my very
supportive middle-eastern born
colleagues said no no no you Marcia you
should go do this project because at my
stage of life you know being middle-aged
sort of maternal figure men are going to
in the Middle East will have a much more
difficult time telling other men that
they have reproductive or sexual
problems you as a Western woman quasi
doctor like maternal you're probably in
a much better position to get people to
talk to you and so I decided that that
might make sense and I wrote that into
my grant proposals you know and I guess
everyone believed me and I was able to
go do the project I will say however in
all of my years of working on this topic
you know it's more than 20 years now I
have never had a single woman not agreed
to talk to me I mean women often really
want to unburden themselves I've never
had anybody disagree or you know reject
being in one of my studies but with men
for the first time in my life I had
refusals you know outright refusal no I
don't have time no I just don't want to
talk about this I'm not in a good mood
and I can say in general it was it was
difficult for a lot of men I I felt like
a lot of men were in a very bad mood
about their situation situations you
know reproductively stressful lives for
a lot of men in the Middle East that
have been made more stressful in the
last couple years and so a lot of it was
men unburdening the things they had been
through I mean you know a lot of
Lebanese in Palestinian and now Syrian
men have been through war often as you
know civilians they have had to flee
their lives are very hard economically
difficult and so a lot of the book is
really about you know just the stresses
of life living in a region where
everything is pretty unstable in your
prologue you talk about
man named Hamza and I think he really
does pay it's a very interesting picture
so why don't you tell us about him yeah
he was I called him Hamza he was a
driver that I ended up you know not only
having him drive me and my little family
I had my husband and two young children
with me in Lebanon but he ended up being
really he became a friend over time and
his story was pretty typical of the
story of a lot of Lebanese young men he
he was a Shia Muslim he grew up in a
sort of poor part of southern Lebanon
his family his father was involved in
one of the Shia political parties and
then when the war broke out they were
like 10 children in the family the war
broke out his father was taken from the
car and killed leaving a widowed woman
with all of these children to support
and so worried that the boys of the
family were going to be conscripted into
militias Hamza like many young Lebanese
men fled he he went actually to the Arab
Gulf and he began working there helped
to support his family back in Lebanon
and he like many young Middle Eastern
men he chose to marry his cousin which
is just a very preferred form of
marriage in many parts of the world and
so she moved to the Gulf with him where
they discovered that you know there was
no pregnancy forthcoming and basically
he it was discovered over time that he
had a pretty serious male factor
infertility problem but like many
childless couples Arab couples they
really loved each other you know it was
a very committed relationship very
loving precious relationship you know as
he put it we have an understanding with
each other she didn't want to leave him
she loved him he didn't want to leave
her even though often when people are
the infertile one they'll often tell
their partner look at your free to
divorce I don't want to saddle you with
my problem and most often people say no
no you're more precious to me than
having children I'm going to stick with
you and so they worked for a long time
to save up money
and eventually to build a home for
themselves when things settle down in
Lebanon and I just happen to meet him
you know he was a taxi driver and you
certain discover in the Middle East when
you ask a series of polite questions
that when people have been married for a
while and there are no children
you know automatically that there's some
sort of an infertility problem because
within marriage it's almost mandatory to
start having children and so he'd been
married for a long time there were no
kids and so I told him what I was doing
there and I ended up you know figuring
out very quickly what the problem was
and I ended up helping him I explained
to him you really really need to use an
assistive reproductive technology to
overcome this problem you'll not get
pregnant otherwise and so I got involved
in his journey to assisted Teknik
reproductive technologies which are
expensive they're physically taxing it
wasn't easy and during the process of
all of this sort of driving back and
forth and helping him get to clinics and
meeting his wife and his family at one
point I realized that among the Shia
most slums of Lebanon that people could
go one of two ways they and one of the
ways that you could go was to be a
sympathizer or a member of Hezbollah the
Shia Muslim political organization which
officially is regarded by the US
government as a as a terrorist
organization and so it's one long drive
back from southern Lebanon I finally
came to that moment of saying gosh I'm
saying you know did you follow this
person or that person and then I figured
out well he was sympathetic with
Hizbollah and we had a very interesting
conversation he said no I'm not a
terrorist I don't want you to think I'm
a bad person
I said you know no no I understand you
know a lot about what Hezbollah does for
poor people in the south of Lebanon and
you know as they do offer a lot of
social they offer offer a lot of social
services especially in the kind of
absence of an official government and so
you know it was this moment of sort of
like well this is just she's a good man
he's my friend he loves my children and
I his political convictions are what
they
our but we have come to an understanding
with each other and I realized you know
in a way this was part of sort of
humanizing middle-eastern man Arab men
who in the Western media you know and in
in scholarship as well they're always
sort of cast in one way especially in
Western media we only hear bad stories
about terrorist religious zealots you
know armed protesters violent men who
make women veil or keep them in purdah
you know we hear many things about
Middle Eastern men Arab men and many of
those things are just caricatures about
who men are and so the book if anything
is just I I think it's a humanizing
account of you know somebody like humza
who yes he sympathizes with Hezbollah
for various reasons but he's a real
flesh and blood kind person who arrived
at that point in his life for you know
certain reasons and the book I think has
many many accounts of men's lives that
you end up thinking well they're just
she no normal human beings like like
everyone else right right and the hamza
story does have a happy ending yes it
does actually after repeated trials of
this reproductive technology there's a
one reproductive technology called XE
intracytoplasmic sperm injection it's a
variant of IVF especially designed to
overcome male infertility he and his
wife tried it three times they had to
move clinics and finally the third trial
was the charm and you know I got a very
early morning call I was in back in the
States from a very excited humza saying
you know doctora guess what happened you
know she's pregnant and indeed on one of
my trips back to Lebanon in about 2009
I you know went to meet him and there
was a beautiful little girl there so
they had had you know a successful
accede pregnancy and a birth of a child
so it was a great ending to that story I
have to say the sort of sad part about
these technologies I mean
I'm sort of although I I see the joy
when they work and there is a lot of joy
when they do work these are not
ultimately highly successful
technologies they're very expensive and
globally assisted reproduction in the
best centers under the best conditions
only works up to 40% of the times and
that's actually a very you know positive
sort of figure for people who have more
serious infertility problems the older
you get the percentage of success
success Goes Down and so they're
ultimately they're the only solution for
a lot of cases of infertility like his
and he was very lucky to have that child
because he had a pretty serious male
infertility problem but this sort of
what shall we say the sort of downside
or the dark side of assisted
reproduction is that it often doesn't
work and in fact a lot of the men in my
study had gone through repeated trials
of XE and IVF and there had nothing to
show for it well your book does show a
very different portrayal of the era of
man versus the stereotypes that we
typically tend to gravitate towards
though thank you very much for being
here today and sharing some of your work
no thank you it's been a pleasure for
more information about Professor in
Hoorn and her research please visit our
website at yale.edu slash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale